you
hi everyone it's Jerry Aman chess calm
right now and I just got paired up with
and Dragonstone so this is a 3-2 time
control so let's see what we let's see
what we get nimzo-indian okay classical
variation let's do a quick strike at d4
and we're gonna go with this line here
I'm prepared to give up my dark square
bishop pretty much have to be with this
line or just the nimzo-indian in general
so I'm hoping to get a lead in
development here or put that to good use
I should say hmm let's play b6 defend my
knight
so I could meet efore with d5 okay they
give a my knight a kick hmm alright this
is a little bit awkward night b7 hmm I
wonder if I've already
laid it okay I don't have very many
options
I wonder if I should have inserted a
five first okay we're gonna run with it
well I don't have very many options
let's go to b7 affin keto tonight at
this early stage in the game or any
stage of the game for that matter is
really not good news
all right let's let's still try and open
it up I realized my opponent has the
bishop pair but when I try to put the
space or excuse me the time advantage
that I have to use here so okay I could
saddle white with an isolated pawn maybe
I could shoot for that I could question
this bishop soon okay their first
gaining a tempo against my queen Knight
here probably not good okay and we're
gonna go here I'm gonna get this Bishop
back I believe I'll end up with doubled
pawns a question I have Queen takes or
pawn takes probably Queen takes if I'm
going to end up with double ponds near
my King mm-hmm
yeah let's go for this so we both have a
structural defect my King you'll have a
fine home here let's see I can open up
the a file for my rook maybe I should
shoot for that right now
or first get in King e7 let's do this
right now maybe I could go in for a
quick capture and then rook to a for
this pawn ever moves this nidal the
Knights placement on b7 will look
amazing
Knight to c5 okay they're not going to
give that square up so easily
let's take this file open and maybe I
should strike right away
hmm I'm a little bit concerned about
some stuff what stuff am i concerned
about I'm concerned about like rook here
pawn push with a bishop check fork also
on Knight d4 I have to be concerned
about knight c6 this move might be a bit
scary cuz on takes Knight there okay I
have this one covered I think 'if II
five a nun takes Knight here I wouldn't
have this move okay so I feel like I
could gain something
let's get this rook working first and
now maybe night here is uh something I
can look into let's go for this right
now I think this was a mistake the
castling move this is increment I'm
hitting two ponds that are now
unprotected c4 hit twice defendant once
it once defended zero so I can take here
I might as well pull the trigger on that
one
he could be pinned but I'll defend got
to do that I'll try to get out of this
pin as soon as possible and I could do
so with this move so I have this Knight
under control he's really well
centralized but he's under control so
they could get a pond back but I'll get
b4 I have all my pieces working there is
this Knight check but it's only a check
really
and just get out of the way and then I'm
attacking the night so let's take here
am I missing anything hmm I don't think
so then I could enter here with tempo
but it's nothing night check King here
Knight d6 rook c6 and then they've
exhausted all the checks so I can't take
care of K so they're going in for that
hmm just back up here King here I'm
exposed two checks over there let's do
this
it's my initial thoughts so let's just
go with it pressure on this night hmm
you know what I don't know about that
actually hmm well I better move quick
yeah I think I would have liked that
square better for my bishop actually not
really liking my decision to do that
okay let's back up 11 seconds not a lot
King here gives another check on a trade
a little bit hmm this Knight is a real
pest hmm I could think about this pawn
move now not really all right my idea is
gonna be I think rook c5 and then Bishop
to c6 and in the meantime he's got that
okay I could go here though I'm gonna
get that pond you see now they don't
have this check the knight has to find a
new home
okay and if they have to go and defend
their night eight seconds eight seconds
eight seconds
my goodness okay I think rook d4 is
needed
hmm I think I'll push the pond on rook
to d4 pawn takes yeah let's go for this
on Knight takes I could take here I'm
stopped upon pawn takes I take here and
then take the knight and I'm winning a
piece not getting mated Knight takes
bishop King takes rook check my king
escapes to f6 I'm a very active bee for
Brooke both rooks are active less than a
minute for my opponent all right let's
see how this one finishes up we'll see
we'll see where the mistakes are made
afterwards
hmm I'm just gonna take here my next
move if a nothing move is played like a
king move or a pawn move but I'm
threatening to just take here
no tricky
I have to watch out for c8 and f5 and my
King is restricted has to defend my
bishop I got a recapture I can insert a
couple checks no ok let's recapture the
pawn up upon but not easy to convert ok
I have that covered
five seconds let's see if I could
convert this I want to trade one pair of
Brooks I think it's not gonna be easy
okay I'm gonna have to block ugly pawn
structure incoming very ugly pawn
structure but it is an extra pawn we're
gonna work with it let's go for a time
gainer everybody loves a time gainer now
how could I try to get something out of
this I'd like to trade him off but even
so it's quite difficult let's cut the
King off maybe this move and my king
could sneak in at some stage inch my way
up still playing under 10 seconds
they're catching up on time that's a
mistake and now I believe I'm winning
they ran right into a pin okay I'm gonna
take like that King and pawn ending is
one so now they're very restricted and
let's March my king up a little bit and
up a little bit more not so fast - watch
out for stalemate tricks as well my king
these are connected past ponds it took a
while for me to realize that but I'm
gonna have a role reversal here I'm
gonna play here and then rook up and
then up to a four stuff let's get my
King out of the way let's go here just
so it the Queen's he's not it's not with
the check now I'm threatening the Queen
with check rook to h1 as well and that's
gonna win the house probably resign
right about here I'm just playing on out
of momentum yeah we'll see okay they
resigned now so let me bring up stock
fish I don't have a good feeling about
this one I'm pretty sure I miss played
it in the early stage of the game but
yeah let's see what stock fish has to
say about this game okay let's see where
we could have improved both of us so
this is an Enzo Indian classical take
stakes and right here after f3 his b6
already mistake I believe it is computer
calls out for d6 and I imagine on b4 in
this case mm-hmm
initially I was thinking well d6 so the
knight can retreat here and that's a
reason that's fine but there's also the
idea of knight a for and on Queen c2
this diagonal is now open
so I'm a bishop watch over the Knight b6
doesn't allow for this idea this Knight
is also making life uncomfortable for
the bishop to fianchetto so is b6 a
mistake uh yeah we could already address
it as mistake that's a bit silly I was
too uh focused in on this follow-up of
e4 right away and I was prepared to meet
that move efore with d5 opening things
up and on b4 now I still have that same
idea with Knight a 4 and Bishop d7 to
defend
I don't know why I was thinking e4 was
the only move here yeah
b6 was too much just to give you an idea
what is it you know there's a valuation
shift there so I should be playing d6
and on e4 I could get on with castles
and just throwing out a couple more
moves Bishop e3 and giving it a little
bit of time to think Bishop to d7 and
well we go on from here there's an
eventual in some sense a tempo tempo
move with rook to c8 I get to activate
and this is a bit uncomfortable for the
Queen to be opposite the rook saw their
mighty even B moves like b5 tied in from
from this point but okay
muevate this is a not good instead I
should be going for d6 but b6 is on
board so I'm really having to fight from
behind it's still calling out for Knight
a four here but if you can cut out my
knight it's close to upon advantage here
for white now I play e5 and this is
already upon advantage with E 5 yeah it
definitely felt like I got away with
something in the early stage this would
have been a good structural change for
white you 597 f4 and look at my Knights
ugly I mean I have I have pieces out on
one move away from castling but it's
hard to see how this night on b7 does
anything you know this Knight just kills
him or this pawn on d4 kills him and so
too does this pawn on e5 ouch
so this really could have gone way wrong
for me they were too quick to go in for
the development and now this is pretty
much back to even in a move d4 is one
that I did not even consider
huh past pond with tempo and I imagine
this is one of the ideas to follow up
with e5 also it's the Queen's will
remain on board with this so Queen d3 e5
see these and these are the these
variations that I'm going through I in
this particular game I find quite
interesting just the different
structural changes and being able to
accurately assess who will stand better
within a particular structure I don't
have very much experience at all I don't
I don't think I can say I have any
experience with this particular
structure so it's uh it's interesting
have d5 Bishop g5 I take so yeah it is
around even now that was a good move
rook to d1 I mean because if this right
away I had planned h6 and well I guess
you could still go ahead and grab that
tempo but you know if you're going in
for right now you know it's the same
same position but with this piece you
know not as active still on his home
square so he first inserts this rook d1
move Queen e7 takes it doesn't like the
takes move instead the immediate
recapture yeah I mean that makes sense
right yeah white should wait white
should wait and wait for this move h6
get on with the recapture so I have to
do this anyway so might as well wait for
me to exist spend this tempo I didn't
have to spend a tempo so light went in
and captured that pin piece recapturing
and it's surprisingly enough starting to
like black just a little bit about a
half pond advantage I responded the
right way here with a5 immediately I did
however consider king e7
yeah I guess this is one of those strike
while the iron's hot while you have that
lead in development look to open the
position you know how many more moves
three more moves before white is castled
however I don't know that white would
really want to Castle more reasonable
would be like castling by hand King F to
King III but this would seem like a a
fine home for the King in the center
it's not too complicated position it's
on a dark square opposite that of my
remaining bishop so you know King g7
okay it's it's fine with King e7 it
likes a five as well night out he five I
didn't consider I took no issues there
kingi seven and this is the move that I
feared he five is being called for
because I can't develop here now because
it takes and my king is being diverted
away from defending my bishop so what
would I do on e5 hmm I'd suggest rook to
a4 but this started to scare me a little
bit you know I can't take this pawn
because of forks on c7 Oh although on
that move I have this and Anton takes
now I could take back the night is
masking the rook from seeing my bishop
okay my bishop ended up here in the game
9d for Bishop d7 rogue h2 c8 so now I'm
up about upon advantage Knight f3 it
liked yeah it's tough
this Knight on b7 it's just a terrible
terrible piece but it starts to look
amazing
as soon as 96 is played hitting a couple
Hans here did shift from here on out I
scooped up upon
I defend is that what it was calling for
there's no I had 92 I just defended I
had 92 detail Bishop takes her up Knight
takes rook
I should be seven rook c7 take my knight
I take here Bishop versus night I'm up
upon it's not the most healthy of pawns
but in a bishop for night pawns still on
both sides of the board mm-hmm I don't
know okay I went with probably the more
raw the safer the safer move the one
that requires less calculation just
defend the threat and get on with that
activating that rook soon get out of the
pin soon look they're okay for hmm
Knight check King f8 was anything else
missed rook c6 this felt very
uncomfortable my other thought was rook
here uh-huh rook c5 and that's not my
first instinct though when your piece is
attacked to look into those moves that
have the you know throw a punch back
rook c6 it's not bad but yeah something
felt uncomfortable to me about doing
that mo this move rook c6 because I'd
really like to activate my bishop
you know rook c5 I guess would have been
better
right there Bishop to EA tonight takes
pawn is threatened did that rook there
and now King e7 yeah so yeah this was
turned out to be not so good
this little rook h4 I improved my King
position the rook comes back over to
defend the knight and h5 is being called
for
I played b5 I think pretty quick in the
game boo it doesn't like that are they
going
and backers are just calling this ending
drawn let's see Knight takes King takes
rook d8 huh
okay since taking the pawn it likes rip
da King e7 rook 8 to d7 ah much
different now by inserting this capture
first my rook is then patrolling the 5th
rank so I could interpose on the f5
square ah so they actually helped me out
by first capturing I improve my rook
position yeah that's that's what's going
on here
so I've rook d8 now they didn't they
didn't do that in the game but if they
played rook d8 and then gave another
check King f6 rook F 1 we get similar to
the game interesting so a little bit of
move order right to give the check first
or to give or to capture you know check
check King here I'm in trouble
rook F 1 and F 7 is collapsing ok
they captured and what about this ending
we're hanging on for a moment I should
be doing something different ah rook c7
you know what here's another thing I
think is important to share right around
this point I was saying I'd like I think
I was saying I'd like to exchange a rook
and I don't know if that's I don't think
that that's objectively best I think I
should be trying to keep both Brooks on
the board keep it a little bit tactical
because maybe it's too easy to go ahead
and draw if it's a technical type where
it's one rook each I was just doing it
with you know I said that with an eye on
time it's simpler to play but
objectively I think I should still try
and keep more pieces on the board
simplifying it is uh yeah I may be
tending more towards a draw but ok King
f sick
I block and yeah so this is like an
insignificant advantage II really can't
convert this what would be the correct
way to hold the draw where didn't well
we know where white slipped up going
into this pin but what's the easiest way
to try and hold this it likes just
improving the King position I guessed up
approaching this pawn right put pressure
on him as soon as possible King f3 and I
give lateral checks here or maybe even
sneak behind to give checks like
something like this let's say well if
King here there's this check maybe if
King here if this check and Ivor block
now this rook could come back here and
then give checks from behind that might
be an idea so immediately approaching
what the king is called for h3 I don't
know if this is really something that
can be converted half pawn advantage for
black but yeah they really just helped
me out I didn't I didn't do anything
special with that a king h2 move in that
that's just the game loser right there I
mean I think at this point we were both
living off for the increment but yeah
this is this is tough I was expressing a
saying during the game I would really
like to exchange my unhealthy pawn one
of my doubled pawns for this guy but
even in those cases it's quite difficult
to convert being up a pawn in this
single rook ending you know and from
there I don't think that thing slipped
the idea here was just to keep marching
what I have now too connected passed
pawns it took a while before they were
connected but once they were in play or
once they were connected it was easy to
convert and just one small detail I know
it was just during blitz but uh you know
staying off of that queening square you
know after it's just a good rule of
thumb you know
stay out of the harm's way if it does
get into a time race type of situation
and if to calculate that stuff just stay
off of that queening square so it's not
coming with Chuck rook there and this is
just pushing through and they resigned
okay
yeah ugly opening b6 should have been d6
in this classical variation and well I
guess lesson learned
my opponent again could have forced me
into not so good structure here and as
usual I hope you got something out of
this video feel free to leave any
comments in the comment section below
and I'll catch you in the next one
that's all for now
take care
you